>> ♪ ♪
DCH
CH
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
IF YOU COULD REMEMBER THAT FAR
BACK, DEMOCRATS FORMERLY BEGAN
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON SEPTEMBER
24th OF THIS YEAR.
TODAY NEARLY 2 MONTHS LATER THEY
HELD THE FIRST PUBLIC HEARINGS.
CNN WENT WALL-TO-WALL UNDER
STRICT INSTRUCTIONS TO SQUEEZE
EVERY LAST DROP OF PARTISAN
DRAMA FOR THE PROCEEDINGS.
IF YOU WERE STUCK IN AN AIRPORT
AND CAUGHT SOME IS OF IT, YOU
COULD TESTIFY HOW POINTLESS AND
TIRESOME IT WAS.
IT MADE YOU REALIZE DEMOCRATS
HAD NO MASTER PLAN FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
THEY HAVEN'T THOUGHT IT THROUGH.
THEY ARE MAKING IT UP AS THEY GO
ALONG AS MOST PEOPLE IN D.C.
ARE.
AND IN THE END IMPEACHMENT WILL
CERTAINLY HURT THEM.
THE WHOLE PREMISE IS TOO DUMB
NOT TO HURT THEM.
THE GOOD NEWS.
WE SOLVED ONE NAGGING MYSTERY
TODAY.
TRUMP'S CRIME.
IT'S NEVER BEEN CLEAR WHAT
DEMOCRATS BELIEVE IS THE
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
NOW WE KNOW.
IT'S THIS.
>> WOULDN'T IT BE WONDERFUL IF
WE COULD GET ALONG WITH RUSSIA.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> WOULDN'T THAT BE NICE?
IF WE GOT ALONG WITH RUSSIA WE
COULD KNOCK THE HELL OUT OF
ISIS.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS AUGUST OF
2016.
IT TURNS OUT VOTERS AGREED WITH
THAT VIEW.
THEY ELECTED DONALD TRUMP
PRESIDENT JUST 3 MONTHS AFTER HE
SAID THAT.
PERMANENT WASHINGTON WAS
APPALLED.
GETTING ALONG WITH RUSSIA IS NOT
CONSIDERED AN ALTERNATIVE VIEW
HERE.
IT'S A CRIME.
LISTEN TO THE STATE DEPARTMENT
VETERAN GEORGE KENT ONE WITNESS
WHO TESTIFIED TODAY THAT
CONFLICT WITH RUSSIA IS THE
ENTIRE POINT OF AMERICAN FOREIGN
POLICY.
>> OUR GAME FOR BY FOREIGN
SERVICE CAREER IS NOT POSSIBLE
WITHOUT A UKRAINE, WHOLE, FREE
AND AT PEACE INCLUDING
TERRITORIES OCCUPIED BY RUSSIA.
>> Tucker: THE TERRITORY OF
UKRAINE IS ESSENTIAL TO AMERICA.
OUR OWN BORDERS MEAN NOTHING.
DEFENDING THEM IS RACIST AND
IMMORAL.
THE BORDERS OF CRIMEAN AND
DUNNBASS, ARE IMPORTANT AND HAVE
BEEN FOR THE ENTIRETY OF MY
FOREIGN SERVICE CAREER!
BACK OFF, DONALD TRUMP, WITH
YOUR WILD IDEAS ABOUT CHANGING
THINGS BECAUSE THE WORLD IS
DIFFERENT NOW AND VOTERS WANT TO
MOVE ON.
MOVING ON IS NOT ALLOWED HERE.
CHANGE IS PROHIBITED.
CAREER BUREAUCRAT WILLIAM TAYLOR
AGREED.
>> UKRAINE IS IMPORTANT FOR THE
SECURITY OF OUR COUNTRY AS WELL
AS EUROPE.
UKRAINE IS THE FRONT LINE IN A
CONFLICT WITH A NEWLY AGGRESSIVE
RUSSIA.
>> Tucker: SO WE NEED UKRAINE
LIKE AN ALCOHOLIC NEEDS A DRINK.
WE ARE ADDICTED.
TOO MANY CAREER DEPEND ON
KEEPING OUR ASSUMPTIONS WHERE
THEY WERE IN THE FALL OF 1977
WHEN FIGHTING THE SOVIET MENACE
CONSUMED OUR FEDERAL BUDGET.
IF THEY DON'T, THEY COULD INVADE
AFGHANISTAN P. SO HERE IN
WASHINGTON THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
DOING.
OUR REAL FEAR IS THE REST OF
AMERICA -- WILL DISCOVER THAT
THE SOVIET UNION NO LONGER
EXISTS AND RUSSIA'S ECONOMY IS
THE SIZE OF ITALY.
THEIR ONLY AIRCRAFT CARRIER
NEEDS TO BE TOWED AROUND THE
OCEAN BECAUSE IT'S BROKEN.
THEIR BEST SCIENTISTS MOVED TO
NEW JERSEY LEAVING THEM UNABLE
TO BUILD A WORKING ESCALATOR.
RUSSIA POSES NO THREAT TO THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT'S WHY KENT AND TAYLOR SPENT
ALL DAY INSISTING THAT RUSSIA
REMAINS A MORAL THREAT TO OUR
COUNTRY.
>> UKRAINE SOON A PATH TO BECOME
A FULL SECURITY PARTNER WITH
NATO.
-- IS ON A.
>> WE AND NATO BEGAN TO PROVIDE
MILITARY ASSISTANCE TO UKRAINE'S
ARMED FORCES WITH MILITARY
EQUIPMENT AND WEAPONS.
>> Tucker: REST EASY, AMERICA!
NATO IS PROVIDING CRITICAL
MILITARY ASSISTANCE TO OUR KEY
ALLY UKRAINE AGAINST THE RED
ARMY.
WE ARE FIGHTING THEM IN KOREA?
WHY?
SO WE DON'T FIGHT THEM IN
CLEVELAND.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DEMAND YOU
BELIEVE.
TRUMP DISAGREES WITH.
THAT HE SAID THIS.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE UKRAINE,
WE ARE THE ONES ALWAYS FIGHTING
UKRAINE.
UKRAINE IS FAR AWAY FROM US.
HOW COME THE COUNTRIES
SURROUNDING THE UKRAINE, HOW
COME THEY ARE NOT OPENING UP AND
PROTESTING?
I NEVER HEAR ANYTHING FROM
ANYBODY EXCEPT THE UNITED
STATES.
NATO IS OBSOLETE AND EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE TO THE UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: UKRAINE IS VERY FAR
AWAY FROM US.
THAT COULD BE TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN
SLOGAN.
LET'S HOPE IT IS.
IT WON'T GET YOU 800 ON THE
S.A.T., BUT THERE IS A SIMPLE
BRILLIANCE TO IT.
IT IMPLIES THE QUESTION THAT
OFFICIAL WASHINGTON CANNOT
ANSWER.
THE QUESTION IS THIS:
WHY ARE WE DOING THINGS THIS
WAY?
HOW DID IT HELP AMERICA?
FOR DAREING TO ASK THAT
QUESTION, THE ONLY QUESTION THAT
MATTERS EVER -- THEY ARE
IMPEACHING HIM.
LISTEN TO ADAM SCHIFF ADMIT
THAT.
>> WELL, THE FOUNDERS DID NOT
INTEND THAT IMPEACHMENT BE
EMPLOYED FOR MERE DIFFERENCES
OVER POLICY, IMPEACHMENT IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL PROCESS THAT
CONGRESS MUST UTILIZE AS
NECESSARY.
>> Tucker: DO YOU WANT TO KNOW
WHAT THE LEFT IS UP TO?
IT'S NOT HARD TO DEFINE.
WRITE THIS DOWN.
LISTEN CAREFULLY TO WHAT THEY
DENY.
THAT'S ALWAYS THE REAL ANSWER.
YOU ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO IMPEACH
A PRESIDENT OVER POLICY
DIFFERENCES SAYS ADAM SCHIFF.